[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est Science Publique votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat de
reportage et d'expertise sur Public
Sénat 90 minutes et deux grands thèmes
liés à l'actualité ce soir d'abord une
journée de grève interprofessionnelle
qui n'a pas bloqué le pays malgré des
perturbations dans les transports et de
nombreux secteurs touchés les syndicats
restent divisés et le gouvernement
annonce une amélioration dans les
stations services
à la sortie du conflit chez So grâce à
l'ensemble des mesures que nous avons
prises nous connaissons aujourd'hui une
amélioration sensible de la situation au
plan national moins de 25% des stations
services étaient en rupture à midi
contre 30% le week-end dernier il y
aura-t-il de l'essence pour les vacances
comment voter le budget et justifier le
49-3 dans ce contexte de crise sociale
de des questions je poserai à mes
invités dans dans une minute et puis
pour notre second thème direction la
Chine pour le 20e congrès du Parti
communiste le pouvoir sans partage de
psy Jinping l'affaiblissement de
l'économie du pays en panne de
croissance notamment à cause de la
stratégie zéro covid les menaces contre
Taïwan le bras de fer avec les
États-Unis on évoquera toutes ces
questions dans trois quarts d'heure
mais d'abord donc cette journée de grève
interprofessionnelle racontée par habite
et Flora sauvage
des raffineries au rut de Paris les
revendications sont les mêmes qu'ils
soient étudiants cheminots ou retraités
salaires c'est pour ça que je suis là
aujourd'hui moi je suis à la SNCF
j'attends de savoir ce qu'elle a SNCF il
va se passer vous augmentation salariale
de cette année après 9 ans de gel
complet des salaires a été de 1% à la
fin de l'année je suis à 1400 euros brut
on revendique le salaire l'augmentation
de salaire qui travaille je fais du 40
heures par semaine je gagne 670 euros
par mois mon loyer c'est 567 l'aide 200
euros je ne l'ai toujours pas touché on
est à la mi-octobre
début septembre c'est vraiment la merde
j'en aurais vraiment besoin ça me
paierait mes courses pour plus d'un mois
150 rassemblements organisaient un peu
partout en France ici à Marseille ils
étaient 2200 à manifester selon la
police les personnels de rééducation
sont d'ailleurs en première ligne mais
pas forcément les premiers mobilisés en
France seuls
6,67% des effectifs étaient grévistes ce
mardi selon le ministère de rééducation
nationale pourquoi on proposera la
reconduction de la grève jusqu'à demain
parce que c'est maintenant que ça se
passe dans le secteur des transports
malgré des piquets de grève mis en place
un peu partout devant les gares les
usagers eux n'ont pas vraiment ressenti
l'impact du mouvement ce matin ça a été
et il y a que le soir qui a eu un
changement de d'horaires j'ai anticipé
j'ai dormi chez un ami à Paris cette
nuit du coup bah voilà pour anticiper
cette grève et du coup ce mouvement du
coup bah pour être à l'heure pour mon
train conséquence la CGT a annoncé que
le mouvement ne serait pas reconduit à
la RATP à des raffineries les syndicats
souhaitaient que ce 18 octobre soit le
départ d'un mouvement marathon cela
ressemble pour l'instant un simple tour
de piste
et je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités béatrigibles à mansois bienvenue
vous êtes géographe directrice de la
revue et redoute Jean-Marie Pernaut
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi vous êtes
politologue chercheur à l'Institut de
recherche économique et sociales et vous
publiez le syndicalisme d'après aux
éditions du retour Benjamin Morel
bonsoir On constitutionnaliste et maître
de conférence en droit public à
l'Université Paris de Panthéon Assas et
j'accue également Laetitia cruppa
éditorialiste bonsoir les Laetitia
peut-être un bilan une question assez
générale Béatrice Giblin pour pour
commencer quel bilan vous en fait de
cette journée de grève
interprofessionnelle tour de chauffe
autour de piste puisqu'on avait annoncé
qu'on se serait peut-être conductible ou
autre bon apparemment compte tenu de la
mobilisation prudemment on va replier
les Gaules et on va attendre de voir
comment les choses évoluent voilà c'est
si la convergence des luttes qu'on
annonce régulièrement chaque autom bon
vous cette fois-ci ça y est on y est on
a bien vu dimanche ça a pas été non plus
un immense succès il faisait beau
c'est vrai ça pouvait normalement tirer
bon sans doute 30 000 personnes c'est
pas je dirais c'est pas en ce moment clé
français ont très envie de se mobiliser
malgré l'inflation malgré effectivement
des salaires trop bas pour beaucoup mais
il y a aussi toute cette inquiétude
aussi internationale qui qui pèse alors
on pourrait me dire justement c'est le
moment de battre le fer non je crois pas
je crois que vraiment ce qui se passe en
ce moment en
Ukraine est une profonde préoccupation
et pas seulement parce qu'on peut avoir
froid cet hiver c'est autre chose qui
qui se passe donc moi je suis pas très
étonnée qu'on n'est pas eu une très très
forte mobilisation on peut pas prendre
ses désirs pour des réalité non plus et
vous Jean-Marie Pernaut quand vous
parlez du syndicalisme d'après c'est
c'est quoi et est-ce que cette
manifestation
elle
est du syndicalisme d'avant d'une
certaine façon non le syndicalisme après
c'est celui qui aura lu mon livre donc
j'ai établi bon un constat de faiblesse
actuel un déficit de puissance des
syndicats je crois la journée comme
aujourd'hui le monde il faut dire aussi
qu'on est quand même si on se situe dans
une histoire de moyen terme on a eu
quand même au cours des années récentes
des 20 30 dernières années si on prend
un peu de recul des mouvements
extrêmement puissants très fort rien à
voir avec la journée d'aujourd'hui il y
avait des millions de gens engagés je
pense au conflit sur les retraites en
2010 il y avait des manifestations
partout dans les petites îles bretonnes
et ça n'a rien produit et je crois qu'il
y a une certaine indifférence du
politique à l'égard de ces mouvements
qui fait qu'ils ont perdu un peu de leur
efficacité et que beaucoup de gens sont
un peu sceptiques sur les manifestations
sans compter qu'à Paris d'ailleurs on a
eu un préfet pendant quelques années qui
a aussi dissuadé physiquement les gens
de s'y rendre donc aujourd'hui c'était
beaucoup plus calme d'ailleurs on a vu
que on avait changé de préfet quelques
quelques années
bon donc je crois qu'il y a
effectivement un problème de puissance
générale qui se pose au
[Musique]
la période actuelle à coup de prime de
bonus
depuis quoi une dizaine une quinzaine
une vingtaine d'années c'est-à-dire que
plutôt que d'augmenter les salaires le
globalement
et puis et puis là là bon le
gouvernement donne des tickets des
choses comme ça on voit bien que c'est
pour passer des périodes mais là on est
le problème n'est plus de de passer des
moments c'est de s'inscrire dans une
tendance faire en sorte que les salaires
ne décrochent pas et donc insister à ce
que une prime c'est one shot même si on
la renouvelle d'ailleurs ça change pas
le niveau du salaire il faut pas oublier
qu'en France toute la protection sociale
sont financement est quand même assis
sur les salaires et beaucoup de primes y
échappent pas toutes mais beaucoup de
prime échappent donc on a quand même et
ça il y a une certaine conscience de ça
mais avoir conscience de ça et descendre
dans la rue à l'appel d'une d'une partie
seulement du syndicalisme c'est c'est
autre chose mais ça veut pas dire que
chacun doit pousser un grand ouf et
retourner
études parce que c'est un pays où le
social est très volatile et où on a vu
avec les gilets jaunes que des choses
parfaitement improbables pouvaient aussi
se dérouler sous le fait de la colère et
c'est un ça reste quand même dans le
paysage Benjamin Morel cette journée
d'action je le disais en titre elle
intervient évidemment plein débats sur
le sur le budget on peut est-ce qu'on
peut dire que les slogans des uns dans
les manifestations d'aujourd'hui
nourrissent moi c'est l'impression que
j'ai eu en voyant les débats à
l'Assemblée cet après-midi nous reste
nourrissaient les interventions des
autres quoi et notamment évidemment des
députés de la nuque un peu toujours
c'est à dire que quand vous regardez les
grands phénomènes de conjonction entre
d'un côté une action parlementaire et de
l'autre la rue dans l'histoire en soi
d'ailleurs à droite comme à gauche et
bien vous avez toujours une mise en
scène de ce qui se passe à l'Assemblée
nationale notamment via de l'obstruction
etc puis de l'autre côté une mayonnaise
qui monte dans la rue et là en effet le
gouvernement a plutôt bien joué sur à la
fois ce qui se passe à l'Assemblée
nationale mais même si on la lumière
viendra aujourd'hui ça va quand même
être compliqué du point de vue de sa
majorité et surtout vis-à-vis des
conflits sociaux en cours c'est à dire
que le rapport symbolique grosso modo
quand vous voulez emporter une
manifestation qu'on voulait emporter un
bras de fer d'un point de vue social
vous avez besoin de deux choses une
capacité de blocage et une partie de
l'opinion qui est derrière vous
aujourd'hui la capacité blocage
notamment à totale et bien les syndicats
en ont fait montre ils en ont moins fait
montres aujourd'hui et de l'autre côté
la bataille de l'opinion publique en
grande partie était perdue parce que
comme ça a été bien dit la problématique
aujourd'hui notamment la problématique
relative au salaire est une
problématique générale qui peut du coup
revenir en boomerang au gouvernement
assez rapidement et la position là
dessus a eu toutes les difficultés du
monde à l'Assemblée nationale à faire
exister cette problématique au-delà de
quelques amendements de l'autre côté les
syndicats ont une approche jusqu'à
présent même si c'était le thème de la
journée d'aujourd'hui que de
nationaliser le débat une approche
extrêmement sectorielle or vous pouvez
arriver à déclencher un effet de greffe
par procuration dans
consulter social le problème
actuellement c'est qu'on a une BCE qui
remonte c'est tout donc sans DT coûte
plus cher et que qui plus est la
politique de la dette en Europe est en
train de se durcir donc le gouvernement
n'a pas vraiment de marge de manœuvre en
la matière il préfère qu'il n'y ait pas
de conflit généralisé pour ne pas avoir
justement à se retrouver face à ce
dilemme aujourd'hui marque un point si
on rentre un peu dans le détail
Jean-Marie Pernaut des syndicats qui
étaient à la on va dire à la manœuvre en
tout cas qui avait appelé à cette
journée interprofessionnelle de grève
aujourd'hui CGT Force Ouvrière solidaire
la FSU est-ce que est-ce qu'on peut
parler d'un axe alors je sais que je
suis souvent retoqué quand je disais
plus radical ou moins réformiste ou
est-ce que ça c'est une c'est une
vieille idée là aussi bah c'est pas une
vieille idée mais enfin c'est une
catégorie le clivée le syndical est-ce
que il faut est réformiste ou radical
etc donc même la FSU est-ce que c'est un
syndicat radical moi je trouve que c'est
une catégorie qui fonctionne pas
véritablement
la CGT signe 85% des accords
d'entreprise chaque année donc si vous
voulez c'est il y a beaucoup parce que
j'ai l'impression que c'est c'est pas
perçu par l'opinion publique ça oui mais
je pense que c'est une catégorie qui
n'est pas opératoire pour décrire les
enjeux du syndicalisme aujourd'hui
la radicalité est-ce que les gens de
chez Total ils sont ils font grève voilà
ce qu'ils sont radicaux parce qu'ils
font grève sur les salaires il y a rien
de plus historique de plus en Allemagne
Ligue des métal fait des grèves sur les
salaires on dit pas que c'est des
radicaux il y a des grèves en Angleterre
en ce moment il y en a en pagaille
d'ailleurs est-ce que pour autant ils
ont un mouvement syndical révolution
faire grève n'a rien radical enfin c'est
toute l'histoire longue du social en
France et vous savez bien que les
représentations collectives dans une
société comptent parfois peut-être plus
même que le poids
réeliance de cette représentation qui
conduit à à dire mais ce n'est qu'une
représentation je pense que mais
béatrisibles est-ce que ce conflit alors
là on focus un peu sur ce qui se passe
chez total energy et on va répéter ce
qui ce qui est dit depuis plusieurs
jours c'est à dire un accord
signé par deux syndicats majoritaires
mais au niveau local et encore une fois
c'est leur droit
dans ses raffineries la grève qui
continue donc ça renforce cette cette
image dont on dont on parlait d'une
certaine façon d'autant plus qu'on
commence à dire que c'est un tout petit
nombre et que c'est on parle de
centaines même arrivé à moins de la
centaine parler de 90 bon Martinez lui
parler de plusieurs milliers voilà mais
il y a un peu le la perception même si
elle est fausse mais elle est ressentie
comme ça qu'au fond un tout petit nombre
de gens sont capables de bloquer ou en
tout cas de nous faire vivre des des
galères or le rapport des Français à
leur voiture à l'automobile est quand
même quelque chose qui est très très
important c'est pas du tout anodin
je pense toujours au week-end ou on voit
les types briquets briquets leur voiture
et je me dis toujours mon Dieu fixe
occupé de leur femme aussi bien pendant
le weekend
dans un journal effectivement un
conseiller d'Emmanuel Macron qui disait
mais là on touche à la bagnole donc
c'est ultra sensible quoi c'est vraiment
la voiture et c'est pour ça que le
gouvernement est si préoccupé si vous
voulez sur justement je reviens sur
total à la fois de faire comprendre que
c'est que quelques-uns déjà pour que
l'opinion publique
indispensable pour la réussite d'une
grève se désolidarisent d'une certaine
façon et qui font très vite parce que il
y a pas il faut pouvoir remplir le
réservoir pour ce fameux week-end de la
Toussaint qui est l'un des weekends les
plus importants dans les déplacements en
France oui en plus on des déplacements
familiaux on va on va on va voir les on
va voir les proches etc et quand même
très très sensible si vous voulez et que
si on peut de l'essence en grande trop
de difficultés sans mettre deux ou trois
heures pour de queue bon on sera bien
soulagé et on partira toujours le
souvenir de 68 ou bon moi j'avais
j'étais jeune à l'époque et tout ça y
est c'était la révolution ou presque et
puis à partir du moment où on a pu
mettre de l'essence dans les voitures
tout le monde est parti en week-end dans
juin et tout s'est arrêté vraiment mais
j'en ai un souvenir extrêmement précis
comme nous on n'avait pas de voiture à
l'époque on regardait ça un peu
franchement déçu et je crois que cette
semaine là est très importante ce que
disait d'ailleurs les syndicats c'est
une semaine importante mais je pense que
cette semaine elle s'est sans doute
arrêtée ce soir peut-être normalement on
verra vous lui intervenir
ce qu'il en est parce qu'en réalité
pourquoi le prix du carburant est un
vrai problème et j'ai bien le prix parce
qu'en réalité vous pouvez toujours faire
la queue à une station-service c'est
désagréable mais fondamentalement le
vrai vrai problème de cette crise c'est
surtout Léos qui ont été inhérentes or
il faut voir qu'avec un salaire médian à
1780 euros par mois je crois et bien
vous avez beaucoup de Français
aujourd'hui qui avec qui plus est des
loyers qui pèsent à peu près 40% du
budget et la répartition du patrimoine
immobilier est un autre sujet
d'inégalité de pouvoir d'achat une
hausse des prix de l'énergie qui à terme
est appréhendée et de l'autre côté un
préalable qui explose et bien là vous
avez une situation qui évidemment en
termes de pouvoir d'achat je vous parle
pas des prix de l'alimentation parce que
quand vous parlez de l'inflation 5%
c'est bien beau mais l'inflation est
calculée sur toute une gamme de produits
les produits alimentaires de base eux
ont cru plus que la moyenne donc
aujourd'hui vous avez une situation de
pouvoir d'achat qui devient un problème
fondamentalement criant et donc
évidemment si vous rajoutez des os à la
pompe et bien vous avez une situation
qui est fondamentalement explosive il
est là fondamentalement le NE du
problème par rapport à ça le
gouvernement a une stratégie de
communication d'autant qui était plutôt
intelligente c'était de 1 dire en fait
ce problème d'inflation n'est pas un
problème de l'État c'est un problème
entreprise par entreprise négocier dans
vos entreprises comme ça vous évitez
d'avoir une forme de coalition des
mécontentements contre le gouvernement
le deuxième élément c'était de dire et
bien vous avez des salariés privilégiés
à total à la SNCF à la RATP ils ne font
pas grève pour vous ils font grève pour
eux et donc ce faisant ne soyez pas
solidaires de ces salariés cette
stratégie de communication qui est
discutable ça a pas marché sur régime
spéciaux en 2019 2020 au Mandela de la
réforme des retraites mais là ça a
plutôt bien fonctionné d'où le fait
qu'en effet la journée d'aujourd'hui est
plutôt une défaite pour les syndicats
alors justement Laetitia à propos de
communication il y a une bataille de
mots là qui il n'y a pas seulement le
gouvernement il y a pas seulement les
syndicats il y a les oppositions
évidemment parce que tout le toutes
l'objectif en fait de toutes ces parties
c'est bien sûr de séduire l'opinion
publique et de mettre les Français de de
son côté par exemple la France insoumise
et la CGT on parlait la pour le
mouvement d'aujourd'hui de grève
générale ça ça a vraiment été un mot
qu'on a entendu répéter c'était vraiment
un terme de communication or ça a été
repris par plusieurs plusieurs médias
moi à chaque fois je me disais mais
pourquoi parle-t-il de grève générale
alors qu'il s'agit de grève
interprofessionnelles donc ça a
fonctionné à partir du moment où il y a
une caisse de résidence dans les médias
ça veut dire que la communication a à
moitié fonctionné après faut voir
jusqu'à qui elle arrive mais Jean-Luc
Mélenchon lui aussi par exemple après
dit vous avez dit Béatrice tout à
l'heure la grande conjonction c'est à
dire la coagulation des luttes alors que
pour le moment CGT et France insoumise
sont encore chacune de leurs côtés alors
de l'autre côté côté patronat et
gouvernement alors le Medef lui a
carrément brandi le mot otage pour
dénoncer le blocage des raffineries
quand Emmanuel Macron lui pense à ses
compatriotes qui galèrent il a dit ça au
Mondial et puis il fait savoir Mondial
de l'Auto il fait savoir aussi via ses
conseillers qui est très agacé et la
première ministre aujourd'hui a dit
carrément à l'Assemblée nationale que
l'État continuerait d'agir comprenait
que il y aurait encore des réquisitions
je vous propose d'écouter au JB Véran le
porte-parole du gouvernement et qui
résume la ligne de l'exécutif c'était ce
matin sur France 2 bloquer une
raffinerie bloquée un centre de dépôt
quand vous avez obtenu l'augmentation de
salaire que vous aviez demandé ou
lorsque d'autres syndicats que le vôtre
ont signé un accord avec l'employeur sur
une hausse de salaire et une
amélioration des conditions de travail
continuez de bloquer l'outil de travail
pour tous empêcher les gens d'accéder à
cet outil de travail n'est pas une
situation normale il n'y a pas que nous
qui le disons la justice le dit aussi
désormais alors on est toujours sur vous
avez raison ce Verbatim une minorité
bloque le pays mais il y a quand même
une légère différence de ton par rapport
à l'envoler très énervé de Bruno Le
Maire hier qui n'a pas plu à toute la
majorité
acceptable et puis un ton vraiment très
ferme alors on a demandé au ministre de
faire mezzovoce alors il y a aussi des
versions des faits qui s'opposent oui
c'est très clair là et c'est compliqué
pour les Français qui ont envie de
choisir un camp écouter par par exemple
ce que disait ce matin sur RFI le
directeur délégué du Medef Patrick
Martin
si le président de la République saga
s'il n'est pas le seul puisque
d'endroits il y a une exaspération on ne
comprend pas ce mouvement qui finalement
à l'origine ne concerne que quelques
dizaines de personnes et qui met en
difficulté beaucoup d'entreprises leurs
salariés eux-mêmes au même moment où
l'activité économique étant dégradation
assez avancée c'est scandaleux que une
une petite partie une toute petite
partie des salariés qui sont pas
d'ailleurs les plus démunis mettre en
péril y compris les emplois de leurs
collègues une toute petite partie des
salariés qui par ailleurs ne sont pas
les plus démunis maintenant écoutez ce
que disait Philippe Martinez c'était ce
matin aussi sur RTL quand il y a un
accord sur la table et qui encore de
nombreux grévistes une majorité de
salariés en grève c'est que la corde ne
correspond pas aux attentes des salariés
je vous rappelle que cet accord prévoit
5% d'augmentation générale des salaires
c'est-à-dire en dessous de l'inflation
dans un groupe qui n'est pas en
difficulté loin de là voilà donc là on a
deux versions totalement opposées je
sais pas si vous avez en tout cas choisi
votre camp mais Philippe Martinez dit
que c'est une majorité des salariés qui
est en grève c'est faux c'est quand même
une minorité des pensions on parle de
tout total ou des raffiner
l'accord avec la direction c'est tout au
total ça on est tout à fait d'accord et
l'accord c'est sur une augmentation de 7
% et pas 5% mais tout ça pour vous dire
que dans cette bataille de communication
c'est souvent le ressenti qui compte et
c'est ce que tente de faire Philippe
Martinez et aussi Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui
annonce une nouvelle manifestation en
novembre ils essayent de de faire
remonter et de coaculer les colères mais
quelle qu'elle soit c'est à dire qu'on
va parier sur la colère des Français
Encore une fois quel que soit son
origine pour s'allier contre le
gouvernement et l'enjeu c'est de savoir
si ils vont réussir ou pas à organiser
ce quatrième tour social qu'ils
annoncent tous les deux depuis la
réélection d'Emmanuel Macron Jean
Pernaut sur le niveau de négociation
pour bien comprendre comment ça comment
ça se passe et peut-être ce qui a changé
dans la dans la loi depuis quelques
années pourquoi on est dans cette
situation où on a un accord général et
malgré tout un blocage qui continue au
niveau des raffines parce qu'il s'est
passé en 2016 à travers la loi el khomri
quelque chose qui n'a pas été tellement
remarqué à l'époque la contestation de
la loi portant sur l'articulation entre
la négociation de branche et la
négociation d'entreprise qu'on appelait
l'inversion des normes etc mais il y a
une chose qu'on n'a pas bien vu enfin
les juristes l'ont vu mais pas pas la
contestation c'est que on a donné un
statut très fort à l'accord de groupe
l'accord de groupe existe on peut passer
des accords dans les groupes depuis 2004
depuis la loi Fillon 2004 mais l'accord
de groupe était un accord indicatif ou
un accord cadre en 2000 en 2016 dans les
Loisel comment ils ont été renforcées
par les ordonnances Macron ça devient il
rentre dans le champ de la négociation
obligatoire c'est à dire que l'accord de
groupe peut décider
de prendre la main sur tous les accords
dans les entreprises ça c'est très
important parce que on est dans ce
problème là l'accord il a été conclu au
niveau de Total group 12000 salariés la
tension elle vient dans des entreprises
qui font partie du groupe avant cette
loi de 2005 l'accord de groupe était
indicatif il y avait le feu dans une
entreprise on se mettait autour de la
table on réglé le problème on peut plus
faire comme ça on peut plus faire comme
ça on peut pas on peut pas oui parce que
le groupe prime le problème qu'on a si
vous voulez oui mais d'accord on peut en
discuter
donne le la mais il interdit pas le
droit de grève dans les établissements à
partir du moment où il y a contestation
dans un établissement donné où les
salariés estient alors les salariés je
fais pour faire vite syndicats ou leur
porte-parole etc estime que ils n'ont
pas été pris en compte par l'accord de
groupe parce qu'ils sont loin du groupe
parce que ils ont des situations
particulières ou parce qu'ils ont
configuration sociale ou syndicales
différentes qui n'ont pas été prises en
compte ils se mettent en grève ils ont
le droit de le faire on fait comment
pour débloquer cette situation on fait
comment et ben on sait pas faire on sait
pas faire parce qu'on verrouille au
niveau des groupes c'est-à-dire qu'on a
recentralisé la négociation collective
on est très très loin des lois oraux de
82 l'idée pendant des décennies on nous
a dit il faut décentraliser la
négociation notamment sur les salaires
pour être au plus près du terrain au
plus près des entreprises pour ajuster
etc et là depuis 2016 on a recentralisé
et c'est très important pourquoi parce
que 70% des salariés du privé
travaillent aujourd'hui dans un groupe
donc c'est pas un truc anecdotique et
des conflits comme cela on n'a pas fini
d'en voir ou une configuration syndicale
donnée dans un établissement ou dans un
groupe pour incontester quelque chose
qui verrouille totalement au niveau d'un
ensemble multiforme ou en plus
l'employeur a complètement la main
c'est-à-dire il peut décider ce qui
négocie au niveau du groupe ce qui
négocie au niveau des entreprises c'est
si vous voulez c'est une rec
centralisation non seulement au niveau
du groupe mais au niveau de la de la
direction de du groupe avec un
syndicalisme avec un syndicalisme à
géométrie variable comme on a partout et
ben vous faites comment et donc ça va
faire ça va multiplier des interventions
comme celle de d'Elizabeth borne la
première ministre qui était à
l'Assemblée cet après-midi et qui
appelait à la reprise du travail on est
exactement dans ce que vous nous
décrivez
il est donc indispensable de sortir de
ce conflit social et je suis intervenu
personnellement pour que le dialogue
social ait lieu chez Total et chez Esso
dans ces deux entreprises dans ces deux
entreprises les négociations salariales
ont débouché sur la signature d'accord
par des syndicats représentant la
majorité des salariés dès lors il n'est
pas acceptable qu'une minorité continue
à bloquer le pays et il est temps que le
travail reprenne
alors je pense que ce que vous nous
dites c'est qu'on va on va effectivement
assister à ce type de blocage alors et
de prise de parole politique dans les
mois ou les années qui viennent mais
Béatrice Gibelin alors là aussi est-ce
que je suis dans une vieille
représentation de du climat ou de
l'histoire sociale et syndicale
française mais ce sentiment que la
France est un pays de blocage social
qu'on n'arrive pas il y a pas de culture
du compromis qu'on arrive pas à négocier
est-ce que vous vous ressentez ça aussi
est-ce que vous l'argumentez aussi mais
en tout cas c'est assurément l'image que
d'autres pays voisins d'une autre ont de
la France ça c'est clair j'ai un
journaliste suisse qui m'appelle hier et
qui me dit exactement ce que vous venez
dire décidément en France tout est
toujours bloqué et il y a un avancé
est-ce que vous attendez le grand soir
d'ici samedi grosso modo c'était ça et
et je pense que bon on n'a pas le culte
du compromis ça c'est moi qu'on en
puisse dire ni le grand savoir-faire
mais c'est vrai en politique c'est vrai
sur le plan social et c'est vrai sur le
plan économique on a on a du mal à
j'allais dire vraiment avoir une écoute
des uns des avec les autres mais comme
vous le rappeliez la CGT signe quand
même 80 % des accords ce qui fait quand
même une très très grande majorité mais
elle ne le clame pas c'est à dire qu'on
va jamais mettre en avant
il y a que Laurent Berger et la CFDT et
qui qui assume le fait d'être réformiste
et puis d'avancer pour la CGT c'est
toujours sûr l'affrontement et le
conflit c'est pas sur un discours
positif mais je dirais inversement on a
un patronat qui est pas plus doué que ça
aussi pour aller à la négociation il
faut être plusieurs pour pour négocier
pour trouver un compromis
avec vraiment
du milieu patronal que j'ai pu que j'ai
pu connaître un profond mépris des
syndicats comme étant des empêcheurs de
tourner en rond et qu'il fallait essayer
de marginaliser le plus possible il y a
qu'à un certain niveau de patronat on
sait qu'on doit faire avec les syndicats
alors vous parliez de stratégie
syndicale on va justement les évoquer
tout de suite grâce à Steve Jourdain
bonsoir Steve bienvenue
si on reste sur sur ce conflit dans les
raffineries il y a deux stratégies qui
s'opposent oui d'un côté la CFDT qui
revendique le dialogue et le compromis
face à la direction de Total la centrale
syndicale on en parlait à accepter une
hausse de 7% des salaires pour l'année
prochaine pour 2023 une prime allant de
3000 à 6000 euros on rappelle que le
gouvernement table sur une inflation de
4,3% l'année prochaine de l'autre côté
il y a la CGT de Philippe Martinez qui
mise sur le rapport de force pour
obtenir des hausses de salaire chez
Total la CGT demande une augmentation de
10% elle parit aussi sur l'extension du
conflit à un maximum
entreprise l'objectif la paralysie de
l'activité économique pour obtenir
encore davantage de syndicats de
stratégie et deux ambiances écoutez
le syndicalisme c'est ça se mesure aux
avancées que ça obtient pour les
salariés qu'il représente et pas au
niveau d'emmerdement qu'il crée pour les
Français en fait on est face à deux
conceptions du syndicalisme la CFDT
considère que pour augmenter les
salaires il faut procéder à des
négociations entreprises par entreprise
voire au niveau des branches à la CGT on
demande à ce que les salaires soient
indexés sur l'inflation et que les
augmentations se fassent dans un cas
national c'est-à-dire en s'appuyant sur
la loi écouter Philippe Martinez
aujourd'hui il renvoie la balle vers le
gouvernement
on puisse partir de du gouvernement
avoir une augmentation du Smic et comme
on le réclame parce que maintenant c'est
urgent une échelle mobile des salaires
c'est-à-dire l'indexation des salaires
sur le coût de la vie c'est plus urgent
et en ligne de mire si on veut bien
comprendre ce conflit entre syndicat il
y a aussi des élections professionnelles
évidemment évidemment il y a de la
politique derrière tout ça il y a des
luttes de pouvoir internes sans même de
la CGT Philippe Martinez quittera son
poste en mars de l'année prochaine il
souhaiterait que ce soit Marie buisson
qui prennent sa suite elle est
actuellement secrétaire général de la
fédération de l'éducation mais ne s'est
pas forcément l'unanimité notamment
auprès de la branche chimie de la CGT
l'une des branches les plus
revendicatives qui aujourd'hui au cœur
de la grève chez Total et puis vous
l'avez dit Thomas il y a aussi un
contexte électoral plus gros global le 8
décembre prochain il y aura des
élections professionnelles dans la
fonction publique aujourd'hui la CGT est
le premier syndicat dans le secteur elle
compte bien le rester en adoptant une
position qu'elle estime plus combatif
que celle de la CFDT merci beaucoup
Steve Jourdain je reste avec vous
Jean-Marie Pernaut sur on reviendra sur
l'objectif finalement le plus important
de ce contexte qui est l'augmentation
des salaires trouver des des leviers
pour pour augmenter les salaires dans ce
contexte inflationniste mais quand même
sur
sur cette guéguerre interne à quel point
de votre expertise de de l'histoire
syndicale à quel point ça peut jouer
dans un contexte comme le celui qu'on
joue aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'on vit
aujourd'hui c'est à à quel point c'est
une bagarre interne à la CGT qui
explique peut-être le conflit dans les
raffineries non les tensions auteur nous
organisations existent il y a des enjeux
tactiques évidemment mais enfin c'est
pas le fond de la fête on voit en plus
la CGT qui est assez divisé en interne
c'est vrai elle se ressource sur les
conflits comme ça parce que il y a on
peut s'en plaindre on peut s'en
féliciter il y a une culture de la lutte
à la CGT qui effectivement est assez
structurantes qui puisse dans la longue
durée et être ici plein le rappelait
c'est une longue histoire d'affrontement
avec avec le patronat et parfois l'état
donc la valeur de la lutte sous de
l'organisation donc en ce moment il y a
pas sa tank pas trop après il y a des
enjeux de congrès comme il y a des
enjeux politiques à l'Assemblée comme
comme il y a partout
il faut pas de se laisser aveugler non
plus par la situation de Total qui peut
se résoudre ou pas d'ailleurs mais qui
peut disparaître de l'actualité très
vite en revanche il y a un contexte de
conflits sociaux très très répandu dans
le pays il y a énormément de bagarres
sur les salaires ça se conçoit il y a
des il y a des grèves d'ailleurs dans
l'interview que vous avez montré de de
Laurent Berger il évoque lui-même
Lubrizol l'entreprise de où là c'est CGT
CFDT il y a énormément d'endroits où la
cndt est dans le conflit sur les
salaires d'ailleurs l'accepte aussi et
c'est dans Diguer le phénomène des prix
après il y a des appréciations diverses
sur le moment le lieu
la façon oui oui non d'accord mais si
vous voulez n'oublions
nationale d'un côté avec parfois des
postures qui font qu'on ait un peu on a
une vision peut-être un peu caricaturale
de chacun des syndicats et puis de
l'autre côté du pragmatisme local entre
dans la vraie vie il y a des il y a
énormément d'actions inter syndicales y
compris avec la CFDT dans les
entreprises aujourd'hui dans la fonction
publique la CFDT en fait partie il y a
des accords interconfédéraux sur
l'assurance chômage sur la réforme des
retraites aujourd'hui le climat entre
les confédérations syndicales étaient
plutôt bon là il y a un point de blocage
et un point dur
le disent frontalement voilà il y a des
divergences bon ça on le sait il y en a
toujours eu entre les organisations la
question elle est plutôt de la façon
dont il les aménage est-ce qu'à un
moment donné on met les divergences au
premier plan où est-ce qu'on les met au
second plan et on essaie de faire en
commun et là-dessus il y a rien de jouer
là-dessus moi j'ai pas entendu que on
était dans une grève dans une guerre
entre entre les deux syndicats il y a un
désaccord qui est ponctuel l'histoire ne
se termine pas avec le conflit le
conflit total et donc on va voir dans
les mois qui viennent mais l'ambiance
aujourd'hui est plutôt une ambiance
inter syndicale d'accord inter syndicaux
alors justement comment augmenter les
salaires c'est ce que tout le monde je
le disais obtenir je vous propose un
témoignage celui du député elle est fit
de l'Essonne Antoine Léo Man pour lui le
levier le plus efficace c'est la grève
par la grève qu'on peut obtenir des
choses en fait la démonstration le fait
que des chauffeurs routiers par exemple
est obtenu en 24 heures de grève 7%
d'augmentation donc ça c'est un signal
qui est envoyé ça veut dire que quand on
lutte quand on se bat et bien on peut
obtenir ces augmentations de salaire et
on peut obtenir l'amélioration du
pouvoir d'achat c'est pour ça finalement
c'est pas beaucoup en réalité c'est à
peine le prix de l'inflation
c'est-à-dire que là les gens sont juste
en train de rattraper le niveau de vie
normal par rapport à la situation
précédente au niveau de l'augmentation
des prix donc voilà c'est par l'action
qu'on peut obtenir des choses et de
toute façon dans toute l'histoire des
droits sociaux et des acquis sociaux
c'est toujours par la lutte qu'on les a
obtenues c'est jamais en restant chez
soi tranquille à son canapé qu'on
obtient des choses c'est en se battant
Benjamin Morel depuis plusieurs jours on
a en tête évidemment le mouvement des
gilets jaunes la capacité d'un parti
politique ou d'une coalition politique
comme la nu par canaliser cette colère
et en profiter ils avaient pas su le
fait ou pas pu le faire au moment des
gilets jaunes pourquoi il y arriveraient
aujourd'hui d'après alors c'est très
compliqué c'est en effet pour l'instant
assez improbable alors le télescopage
avec les avec les débats l'Assemblée
nationale peut éventuellement être une
façon de le faire c'est à dire que vous
faites exister les débats au sein de
l'hémicycle et vous essayez et bien
d'avoir justement ce lien avec le
mouvement social avec les préoccupations
des Français par ailleurs et bien la
majorité relative à l'Assemblée
nationale fait que il y a un focus
médiatique beaucoup plus grand
aujourd'hui sur ces débats
parlementaires donc ça peut jouer parce
que dans l'idée de représentation il n'y
a pas seulement l'idée de ressembler à
il y a également l'idée de agir au nom
de et ça c'est extrêmement important
quand vous voyez un orateur à
l'assemblée qui semble dire ce que vous
vous ressentez les difficultés qui sont
les vôtres il y a un effet
d'identification et donc ça peut marcher
après la question c'est est-ce que la
nuque est la mieux placée pour justement
tirer les fruits de cette situation on
voit qu'il y a également le
rassemblement national qui joue sa
partition qu'en réalité tous les partis
aujourd'hui jouent leur partition sur
cet aspect là les syndicats également et
là en effet cet effet d'identification
ne favorise pas forcément la nuque
surtout si vous avez des fragilités qui
sont liées à des manifestations qui ne
sont pas assez suivies etc mais
fondamentalement on est dans une
stratégie qui peut marcher mais c'est
intéressant parce qu'on parle de blocage
et c'est aussi un terme qu'on emploie à
l'Assemblée à propos de l'utilisation du
49-3 et avec presque la même les mêmes
leviers qui qui consiste à faire porter
la responsabilité à l'un ou à l'autre du
10 blocage il y a une forme de stratégie
de communication qui est une stratégie
de communication des deux côtés qui se
ressemblent c'est à dire que pour le
gouvernement il s'agit de montrer que si
le 49 fait alinéa 3 qui clairement est
annoncé dès le départ vous avez une
majorité relative il est évident qu'on
va passer par un 49 alinéa 3 il faut pas
se mentir mais la stratégie politique du
gouvernement est de dire attention ce 49
aliné à 3 on ne veut pas en réalité
c'est parce que l'opposition est
méchante parce que l'opposition n'est
pas constructive et que donc on est
contraint d'en arriver là
idem pour les grèves on ne voudrait pas
en arriver là mais les syndicats nous
obligent leur acquisitionner certains
amendements pour mourir attention c'est
à dire que ça dans le cas du 49 aligné à
3 c'est toujours le caste bien que vous
pouvez intégrer des amendements et de la
majorité et l'opposition et que c'est
pas tellement le budget qui leur pose
problème que les textes plus tard il
s'agit de pas trop faire avaler de
couleuvre à LR et à la majorité c'est de
bonne politique mais la stratégie de
communication là-dessus se ressemble
tout comme la stratégie de communication
des oppositions dans l'opposition à
l'Assemblée nationale il s'agit de dire
mais écoutez le gouvernement ne veut pas
négocier le gouvernement n'est pas dans
une position d'ouverture nous avons
proposé des amendements ces amendements
ils sont populaires regardez le
gouvernement les refuges pour les
syndicats il s'agit également de dire
nous avançons des propositions
raisonnables ces propositions ne sont
pas entendues donc le mouvement social
est une la manière dont se débat de
communication va être arbitrée n'est pas
si évident c'est à dire que pour
l'instant on est au début malgré tout
d'une crise économique on revient aux
conséquences de l'inflation qui est
fondamentalement profonde ce qui est
certain c'est que si jamais le
gouvernement perd cette bataille de la
communication ça risque ensuite d'être
très très compliqué pour notamment
maîtriser un sa majorité et puis de et
bien une opinion qui peut très très
rapidement se gilet jaune idée
Jean-Marie Pernaut si l'objectif c'est
c'est une augmentation des des salaires
est-ce que dans le contexte actuel
contexte économique et le contexte
politique la grève est effectivement
pour vous le meilleur levier ça l'a
sûrement été historiquement est-ce que
ça l'est toujours aujourd'hui
c'est quoi les autres moyens parce que
si vous me parlez du dialogue social
j'aime pas ce mot dialogue social donc
je l'emploie parce qu'il est dans l'air
du temps mais enfin il y a partout des
rapports de force si vous regardez
comment fonctionne les systèmes à
l'étranger parce qu'on dit toujours en
France justement est-ce que nous on fait
du blocage
même en Allemagne on connaît bien ce
système qui nous présente pas beaucoup
de grève mais sa solidité tient au fait
que les syndicats sont toujours capables
de la faire le patronat le sait que
quand il a fond ça coûte très cher donc
on fait attention à ne pas trop aller il
y a des procédures très sophistiquées
pour éviter qu'on en arrive là il y a
des grèves d'avertissement on regarde on
se revoit on négocie le patronat et
peut-être aussi un petit peu moins buté
que le nôtre pour devancer tel ou tel
truc mais rien n'avancerait si les
syndicats eux-mêmes étaient pas capables
de montrer leurs muscles quand ils
n'arrivent plus à faire des grèves là le
rapport de force change beaucoup il faut
bien voir que la la notion que ça prenne
de la grève ou pas la notion de rapport
de force est essentielle il suffit pas
de s'asseoir autour d'une table ça tout
le monde vous le dira c'est n'importe
quelle stratège que ce soit du côté de
l'employeur ou pas on a besoin de voir
quelle est la capacité qu'on ceux à qui
on dit non de réagir et de me créer un
certain nombre d'ennuis et tous les
systèmes de relations sociales
fonctionnent sur cette base là on n'est
pas dans un monde de bisounours ou entre
gens bien aimable autour d'une table ou
du ah bah oui ça serait bien que etc ça
ne marche pas comme ça il y a des
rapports de force alors comment on les
construit parfois on n'a pas besoin de
la grève parfois on en a besoin et je
trouve que là-dessus
d'ailleurs il y a pas de temps de grève
que ça enfin on ne fera pas croire que
la situation économique du pays est
grave aujourd'hui c'est franchement pas
à cause des grèves parce que depuis 30
ans le taux de grève dans le pays est
quand même très très abaissé depuis les
gilets jaunes on n'arrête pas de dire
que les cendres sont encore fumantes et
que ça va repartir tout le monde les
syndicalistes les politiques là pendant
la campagne présidentielle on avait à
peine réélu Emmanuel Macron qu'on était
déjà sur cette thématique les médias la
partageant aussi donc ça a vraiment été
le thème je trouve central moi de l'été
même regardez cette rentrée que on va
avoir tout le monde sera dans la rue la
France sera voilà façon et on a rien on
a on a quelques milliers je veux pas
entrer dans le la bataille des chiffres
mais pour le moment ça ne prend pas
comment explique-t-on que
parce qu'il veut se passer dans les
prochains jours nous sommes de la vie
même si on avait un rapport sénatorial
qui est intéressant là-dessus mais c'est
en tout début d'émission c'est la
question de la de la lassitude
finalement ou la fatigue de l'opinion
face à un contexte économique
international peut-être qu'il y a
anesthésie la capacité de colère qu'il
faut pas sous-estimer une inquiétude
profonde c'est peut-être parce que c'est
ma partie sur l'impact de
l'International de ce qui peut se passer
où les choses sont graves il faut pas
les sous-estimer c'est c'est pas ça nous
concerne pas non ça nous concerne et je
pense qu'il y a cette inquiétude de là
qui est pas qui est pas négligé si vous
voulez ce n'est pas ça n'empêche pas
qu'on puisse se battre très légitimement
pour des augmentations de salaire et je
pense qu'en France on a eu vraiment un
décrochage des salaires et des bas
salaires et qu'il est nécessaire c'est
vrai et que je pense que l'opinion
publique ça elle va le partager alors il
faut pas qu'on se focalise effectivement
juste sur total d'énergie sur les
raffineries sur l'essence et je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec vous on peut
parfaitement avoir un contexte qui
puisse s'enflammer mais il sera aussi
fonction de la grande inquiétude de ce
qui se passe autour Benjamin Morel oui
actuellement ça reste extrêmement flou
alors je peux vous donner les lieux
communs de la science politique et vous
regardez avec un air profond et vous
dire les révolutions et les moments les
Jacquie etc ça n'arrive qu'à le sortir
des crises et pas pendant les crises
parce que les gens ont la tête sur le
guidon en réalité il y a pas de règles
historique on n'en sait rien c'est un
lieu commun fondamentalement aujourd'hui
vous avez une partie des Français qui
ont du mal à joindre les deux bouts et
cette situation là elle est évidemment
explosive quand vous avez pas les moyens
de nourrir par une partie de votre
famille parce que les prix de
l'augmentation les prix d'alimentation
ont explosé qu'est-ce que vous faites et
là il y a en effet une vraie question et
par rapport à ce qu'on évoquait tout à
l'heure on entendait Antoine et au
mentir il faut danser Philippe Martinez
il faut réindexer les salaires sur
l'inflation alors que propose Fabien je
te propose Fabien Roussel mais le
problème le problème alors oui elle est
traitements des fonctionnaires les
traitements des fonctionnaires donc
quasiment pas bougé depuis les années
Sarkozy il y a eu 3,5% d'augmentation du
point d'indice cette année mais très
clairement c'est ridicule les
professeurs les les policiers etc ont vu
leur pouvoir d'achat s'effondrer en
disant donc il y a des revendications
qui là dessus sont légitimes le problème
c'est comment vous les traitez et si
vous réindexer les salaires sur
l'inflation le risque c'est de rentrer
dans une spirale d'inflation ce qu'on a
connu dans les années 70 et surtout
aujourd'hui comme je l’évoquais et bien
si jamais vous indexez les salaires sur
l'inflation vous attaquez un tissu
économique fragile et donc vous risquez
d'affaiblir pas total mais des emplois
etc qui aujourd'hui sont dans une
difficulté fondamentale on rembourser
les PGE il y a beaucoup de de faillite
etc il y a un effet retard des faillites
qu'on imaginait dans les premiers temps
de la crise commune et le gouvernement
aujourd'hui dans une situation où il
essaye à la fois de ménager la
compétitivité des entreprises en même
temps d'éviter une hausse du chômage qui
serait inférente de l'autre côté pour
les fonctionnaires là encore une fois
vous creusez la dette si jamais vous
voulez arriver à régler le souci et ben
il faut rentrer dans un bras de fer avec
l'Allemagne c'est pas évident on va
l'année prochaine emprunter ato
extrêmement important pour arriver à
rembourser le principal à la BCE qui va
en fait ne faire que détruire de la
monnaie qu'on pourrait débattre de ces
sujets là et fondamentalement si on veut
arriver à des battes de ça il faut
rentrer dans un bras de fer européen
dont la France n'a aujourd'hui pas les
moyens allez on termine là-dessus merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat je rappelle le titre de votre
livre Jean-Marie Pernaut le syndicalisme
d'après publié aux éditions du retour
merci beaucoup d'avoir participé à ce
débat